Come on, boy, please wake up.
[Music] I
understand why only Gashi-sama and Thread-sama can enter this room with their useless colors. A woman would be overwhelmed by his sex appeal, and a
man would have pushed her down. It's
truly a sinful nature.
You're like a bug with a starting point.If you collect the scent of this bug and turn it
into a love potion, it might sell well.If you're
okay with it, I'll let you prepare a new room.I
don't really understand what you're talking about, but it's a good chance to go to Kadoido.  I do
n't know if you won't tell me clearly what you want.I'm going to
do something about it for the time being.Okay, so there's a stable
near the well.